[Music]
wasp is the legacy character she's right
there on the cover of Avengers number
one finally every single character from
that first issue of Avengers is here on
the big screen we saw the original wasp
a Janet Van Dyne in a brief flashback in
the first movie and at the end of the
movie we finally saw a new suit and Hank
Pym realizing of course this suit
belongs to his daughter hope it's about
damn time now an ant-man and wasp we see
her in all her glory watch this
she gets to wear this suit that she's
been coveting her whole life she so
desperately wanted to follow in the
footsteps of her parents who had been
incredible superheroes in their day and
so she's finally doing that hope as this
incredible capability and incredible
drive as a fighter as a scientist to be
this hero she's the toughest one of it
movie she lives to be wasp she lives to
be the superhero mantle all of my weak
this film is primarily a fun clever
emotional story of family because of the
quantum realm is where copes mother
Janet Van Dyne the original wasp had
been lost presumably forever I was in
the quantum realm and I think I saw it
Janet
now the mission becomes can they go down
there and bring it back her mom this
technology gets into the wrong hands
it's just chaos and the stakes are so
high we don't have much time a man wasp
also connects directly to Avengers for
these characters are going to be very
important going forward and a wasp
teaming up
rated pg-13 so how long have you been
Antonin again no uh I just sort of
happened it's like bad guys like you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch your
back
like a partner
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be ghosts
like walks through walls to stuff slowly
tick and now supposed to take over the
world or whatever who would have
believed that in your hour of need you
would turn the house happy because we
robbed you
do you remember that's us feeling Jesse
Pratt is
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny I
was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you 65 feet 65 if you two
are finished comparing sizes 65
[Music]